I have lived in England now for 10 years
with my lovely daughter who was planned
poorly as it turns out very poorly her
father and I are not together anymore
but we are still really good friends is
a lie I tell to protect her it's fake
news we're enemies we are enemies and
she's English I love having a British
child it's like having a tiny and
ineffective Butler yeah but where is the
drink that I ordered from you 10 minutes
ago yeah oh and that's how she talks the
British are sneaking into their own
country through my body that's what's
happening over there yeah ha and brexit
has severely undermined me as a parent I
tell her to eat her vegetables she tells
me to stop being a burden on her
national health care system I'm not I'm
not but she believes that because she's
the baby she's a dumb baby do we have
any single mothers in know they're at
home where they belong just checking
just to be sure a single mother is an
asset not a liability do you know how I
know that if I were a man I wouldn't be
single I'd be eligible wouldn't I
wouldn't I thank you I own property they
would make me the bachelor they really
would there'd be like how does he do it
he's raised a gorgeous young daughter in
his only 33 years old fresh out of high
school how does he do it he has all
these little animals those little dogs
that shiver and piss from in their eyes
he's not crazy he's sensitive
there'd be memes of me like vacuuming
with no shirt on just making cakes for
her school sale they'd be like Oh does
it do it and I'd say things like if you
think my hands are full you should see
my heart that's what I would say and
there would be YouTube videos of me
going viral just braiding her hair
before school they go how does he do it
I'd say well I take three equal sections
of hair and then heroically I fold one
over the others and so on like any idiot
could do and there would be disney
princess type women lying around the
block to save my life that would be my
life but it is not my life a man broke
up with me recently and the reason was
he said you don't make me a priority you
said that to me an immigrant single
mother you don't make me a priority
you're always working and looking after
your child but I paid for everything in
this relationship I was like me it
literally says priority on your bags
every time I buy you a plane ticket and
I always check back into economy to see
how you're doing on the fly you'd say
you don't fight for me Katherine you are
not the last Stella McCartney dress in a
sample sale
what do you want me to do
I'm busy I'm learning Hebrew in case I
meet a Jewish man I want to keep my
options very open I've not met one I
just you never know what do you have to
pull a fast Ivanka to stay in the game I
want to be ready learn and Ebro is very
hard and it takes ages I could have a
pilot's license by now or like
grandchildren it's taken a long time and
I love Jewish parents I want to be one
because they create a real
set of obstacles if you want to date
their kids you have to learn Hebrew give
up bacon and stop believing in heaven
imagine my Irish parents they have no
rules they'd just be like get her home
if it's on your way relatively uninsured
we all know how that worked out not well
and I can't get this dress off by myself
do you like my dress someone's in today
it's a gorgeous dress but I'm trapped in
it now we're very arrogant women going
out and clothes that we can't take off
alone women's fashions are a beautiful
prison if Houdini wore Vivienne Westwood
he would have drowned every time why do
we do this
why do we do it and so who do I have I
got a butler at home but I'm not
supposed to wake her up she's too little
I have done I've been trapped in the
dress I knew I couldn't sleep and it I
went into a room one night like 3:00
a.m. that's not appropriate she's only
kid in her class it takes a siesta I
said honey wake up she's like mommy yeah
mommy is trapped in her dress again she
unzipped it she's so wonderful and I'm
walking out of a room with it half off
now just uh if my life couldn't get me
where it's at the door she just says
mommy maybe you should start asking the
uber driver
you know I deleted that up for political
reasons
you